[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
en un acto de provocación en torno a la
crisis migratoria los gobernadores
republicanos de Texas y Florida en
Estados Unidos iniciaron la pasada
Primavera una controvertida política de
envío de migrantes en autobús hacia el
norte a ciudades como Nueva York desde
entonces la urbe ha recibido a unos
44.000 solicitantes de asilo pero a
pesar de ser conocido como un lugar de
acogida para los migrantes Nueva York
nunca se había enfrentado a tal
afluencia por lo que la ciudad no da
abasto y se plantea otras soluciones
como enviar a los migrantes a Canadá
Esta es la historia la Estación de Buses
más concurrida de Nueva York Port
Authority se ha convertido en un centro
de acogida de migrantes las autoridades
locales que en su día criticaron a los
gobernadores de Texas por enviar a los
migrantes en buses hacia el norte hacen
ahora lo mismo aquí en Port autority la
ciudad da billetes gratuitos a los
migrantes que quieren ir a la frontera
norte de Nueva York y cruzar a ca su
lema salió de Perú en abril del año
pasado en junio cruzó la frontera sur de
Estados Unidos por México y llegó aquí a
Nueva York es difícil llegar a Estados
Unidos y es más difícil mantenerse
Zulema ha intentado buscarse la vida
aquí pero sus papeles para trabajar
tardan demasiado mientras espera
trabajado como voluntaria ayudando a
asesorar a otros migrantes pero ahora ya
también se sube a ese bus gratuito que
va a la frontera norte pero sí 100%
agradecida porque en Nueva York les da
casa gratis les da comida gratis y yo
como migrante me voy agradecida
inclusive un poco triste de no haber
logrado mi sueño americano la mayoría de
los migrantes que se dirigen al norte
son latinoamericanos Pero hay otros
africanos como Mohamed que es de Sudán
Busco una vida mejor Busco seguridad
Busco trabajo un trabajo excelente
el autobús se dirige al norte a
plattsburg Nueva York el viaje dura seis
horas desde plattsburg hay 30 minutos en
taxi hasta la frontera de Estados Unidos
con Canadá no me ofrecieron la
oportunidad que uno esperaba ya que los
trámites son muy complicados es muy
costoso de hecho ayer estamos en
situación de calle y fue que bueno
decidimos mirar para Canadá que ser un
país hermoso
una vez en el taxi las familias
migrantes se dirigen al paso fronterizo
de roxanne Road una zona rural del
Condado de Clinton en Nueva York
Canadá es bueno es un buen país queremos
vivir Allí más que aquí
el año pasado más de 39.000 solicitantes
de asilo cruzaron a Quebec a través de
roxanne Pero ese número es también un
desafío para Canadá este último mantiene
un acuerdo de Tercer país seguro con
Estados Unidos que dice que cualquiera
que cruce por pasos fronterizos
oficiales será devuelto y tendrá que
solicitar refugio en el primero de los
dos países a los que llegó pero no pasa
lo mismo Con quienes entraron por cruces
no oficiales de ahí el vacío de esta
Norma Qué pasa cuando los migrantes
entran a Canadá lo vemos en el siguiente
informe
Este es el paso no oficial de rock and
roll un cruce que une al estado de Nueva
York en Estados Unidos y a Quebec en
Canadá este tramo cubierto de nieve es
el último en su viaje hacia el país más
al norte de América
todos los días cientos de personas
procedentes de Haití Venezuela Colombia
e incluso de algunos países africanos
pasan por esta frontera con el objetivo
de quedarse
su primera parada de un largo y
peligroso viaje son estos refugios
así lo cuenta Esta haitiana solicitante
de protección
Caminé cuatro días hay gente que dura
ocho días otros mueren en el camino
porque era muy muy difícil hay montañas
No tenemos comida no hay nada
por donde caminas solo hay agua pasas el
río subes la montaña bajas fue muy muy
difícil nos encontramos algunos cuerpos
en el camino pero gracias de Dios
salimos sanos y salvos con eso
después de su registro estas personas
son llevadas a un puesto fronterizo
oficial para presentar una solicitud de
asilo entre el 50 y el 60% de dichos
pedidos son aceptados pero el cruce de
roxanne es motivo de controversia y
existen pedidos para su cierre ya
tenemos personas muertas en nuestra
conciencia cerrar roxanne claramente
significa tener más personas que
intentarán cruzar Campos en un país
donde es invierno donde es muy peligroso
estamos hablando de mujeres embarazadas
estamos hablando de familias con niños
por lo que cerrar rock and roll para
nosotros es poner a todas estas personas
en peligro Y es que sólo 5000 personas
cruzaron el pasado enero por aquí lo que
pone a prueba al gobierno canadiense y
su capacidad para responder a las
llegadas y a una eventual crisis
humanitaria
y ese es el motivo de la polémica porque
pese a la acogida la capacidad de las
localidades fronterizas de Canadá está a
tope el gobierno de la provincia de
Quebec le exigió al Primer Ministro
Justin trudeo dejar de promover la
llegada de solicitantes de asilo hasta
que inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante sf24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]